[Musique]
j'ai eu un gros choc qu'il ya quelques
années lorsque j'ai réalisé que la
société attend mon image que les choses
qui m'indigne étaient présents dans mon
quotidien
j'étais outrée des commentaires haineux
que je voyais circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux des gens j'entretenais des
potins rempli jugement autour de la
machine à café
je dénonçais la rage au volant mais il
m'arrivait de donner de petits coups de
volants haute sphère de léger freinage
brusque
juste pour indiquer à la voiture
derrière qui me suit d'un peu trop
proche puis que ça m'énerve le
sensationnalisme des bulletins de
nouvelles qui m'horripile eh ben j'en
partage l essentiel autour de la machine
à café
ce qui active et ma prise de conscience
et que je le sais bien que dans le fond
la société
c'est la somme de ce que nous sommes
alors inévitablement joué un rôle dans
ce que j'ai observé
si je souhaitais observé quelque chose
de différent je devais jouer un rôle
ferrand j'ai donc fait ce qu'on fait
souvent dans notre vie professionnelle
je vais suivre des principes directeurs
trois grandes valeurs
trois mots qui ont modifié ma
trajectoire
l'exemplarité la responsabilité et la
confiance avec l'exemplarité ben j'ai
vite d'exiger des autres que j'exige pas
d'abord de moi même en fait je m'assure
que ce que je fais est en cohérence avec
ce que je dis et même ce que je pense
j'avais l'habitude de faire de très
belles affirmations un peu comme on
partage et belles stations sur nos
réseaux sociaux mais sans jamais
vraiment appliquer l'arrêt sont comme le
jour je me suis entendu dire avant
l'adolescente qu'on avait pas besoin
d'alcool pour avoir du plaisir dans une
fête quand j'essayais de penser à la
dernière fois où j'avais choisi tu ne
pas consommer d'alcool dans un environ
dans festif j'étais embêté pour être en
cohérence avec mes valeurs je devais
arrêter de faire l'affirmation ou
mettent en action puisque j'avais des
filles je suis plutôt disons le
excessive
j'ai entamé une année de sobriété rien
de moins alors c'est ni facile ni
parfait mais ce qui est génial c'est que
j'aime n'ont plus besoin d'avoir la
conversation avec mes adolescents parce
qu'ils se trouvent qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus influencée par ce que je fais que
parce que je vous rassure
l'exemplarité ont rien à voir avec la
perfection mais j'observe que depuis
j'ai vite d'exiger des autres que
j'exige pas là bordeaux - game jeu
beaucoup plus indulgente envers tout le
monde
ensuite je prends la pleine
responsabilité d'énergie que je diffuse
g choix de mes actions et surtout de mes
réactions j'ai choix de réagir et
surtout la façon dont je vais réagir
ça me rappelle une conversation que j'ai
eue avec mon père et une trentaine
d'années je vais faire réparer klaxons
marc renaud alliance 1984 alors je vais
y ai demandé de me prêter de l'argent au
lieu de me répondre oui ou non il vit
bien ce que tu es frein fonctionne je
suis frais fonctionne il ne mettait pas
besoin de tant que l'action c'était
frais fonctionne j'avoue quelle époque
j'ai vraiment juste compris qu'ils
voulaient pas me prêter d'argent c'est
devenu de mille histoires préférées
une image puissant de maîtrise de soi
choisi d'utiliser davantage mes freins
en prenant un moment de recul pour mieux
considérer la perspective de l'autre et
de moins utiliser mon klaxon en faisant
valoir aux efforts ma propre perspective
vous avez pas idée de la richesse des
conversations que je peux avoir lorsque
je réussis à me placer en position
d'ouverture de respect et de partage
finalement la confiance la confiance en
moi la confiance aux autres la confiance
en l'humanité
j'ai pris conscience de ma petite voix
vous savez la petite voix intérieure qui
parfois sort de nulle part mais à
prendre place
la vienne avait une attitude franchement
désagréable elle avait l'habitude de ne
pas être très gentille avec moi dès que
je démontrais de l'audace ou vous
exprimer mes rêves mbs et métaux qui tu
te rends je travaille fort sur notre
relation souhaite qu'on devienne le
meilleur ami je l'entend de plus en plus
une vire des choses comme à lima belfond
ce seul mérite tellement je fais
confiance aux autres parce que je
découvre qu'on est beaucoup plus pareil
que de vous faire et que les gens sont
fondamentalement bon j'ai confiance en
l'humanité parce que nous sommes la
somme de ce que nous sommes et nous
sommes tous en évolution
ma trajectoire a été modifié parce que
le regard que je pose sur le monde a
changé
je pose un regard beaucoup plus
empathique sur ce qui m'entoure mon
annif sobriété s'est transformé en un
nouveau mode de vie le 1er janvier déjà
ternie il s'avère que ça c'est ça a été
beaucoup plus qu'une leçon pour mais
intéressant ça a été une opportunité
extraordinaire d'apprendre à reconnaître
à me respecter et à m'apprécier on dit
qu'une transformation s'opère un pas à
la fois vers une destination mais
destination à moi c'est la sérénité
imaginez si j'avais raison
imaginez si on pouvait changer le monde
une personne à la fois merci
[Applaudissements]